Sebastian I'm just I'm I'm just about
out of time but I have to ask you an
individual question
um you obviously are gearing up this
year to play Bucky again it's been a
little while since you've played the
role is it something that you are
looking forward to getting back to uh
and what is it are what can you tease
people about Thunderbolts no of course
like I you know as always it's it's
always a pleasure going back and and you
know I think now we have like it's an
exciting time because this character can
kind of go every which way we sort of
opened up the door for him in a lot of
ways but I I haven't read the script I
still hasn't have not been scented so
um
it's
it's pretty much on par as as how it
usually goes so I've heard good things
um I'm also I think this that the film
I'm really excited about the cast like
there's a lot of great people in there
like oh that I was really I'm looking
forward to working yeah David Harbor was
telling me that he's looking forward to
shooting stranger things five and
thunderbolts at exactly the same time
that's crazy yeah I don't know how he's
gonna do that
uh Atlanta that's out right maybe he's
not in our movie that much I don't know
I didn't say that he's a great guy I
love David